une coiffe d'apparat des amériques un
pagne de guerriers ou encore le premier
masque en provenance du continent
africain voici quelques pièces parmi la
cinquantaine exposées à la bibliothèque
municipale de versailles ces pièces sont
une infime partie de la collection
amassée par charles 10 petit frère de
louis saez qui comprend plus de 500
objets la collection du comte d'artois
était une collection extraordinaire qui
était destiné à l'instruction des 2,7
ficelé duc d'angoulême et de berry donc
elle comprenait des instruments de
physique de chimie beaucoup de spécimens
naturaliste et surtout une magnifique
collection d'objets du monde entier les
objets qui étaient perçus comme exotique
mais reflétant les us et coutumes des
peuples éloignés aujourd'hui la grande
majorité des pièces de cette collection
est stocké au musée du quai branly
jacques chirac la bibliothèque conserve
tout de même une quinzaine de pièces le
lycée hoche de versailles héberge lui
aussi une partie de la collection le
lycée hoche a hérité des collections
d'objets d'histoire naturelle
de l'ancien cabinet de curiosités du
comte d'artois et notamment celles qui
avaient été collectés
par fayolle qui était un ancien commis
au bureau des colonies d'amérique et si
le compte était aussi attaché aux
amériques il faut rappeler que jusqu'en
1803 la louisiane étaient toujours une
colonie française ils ont donc rapporté
de nombreux objets de la tribu
amérindienne chaque pas au le projet
collaboratif avec la nation jocktane est
né du souhait de valoriser ces pièces
qui proviennent de leur territoire
ancestral dans le cas de cette
exposition l'exposition la curiosité
d'un prince est à visiter jusqu'au 11
décembre